hey everybody it's Mike from amorphos
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about uh value
areas you know sort of trading around
value areas and their importance in the
order flow so
um before I jump in if you enjoy my
videos you know I'm trying to get one up
every single day at least one
um don't forget to subscribe and click
the notification Bell so you don't miss
any new upload that I do and if you find
today's video helpful
be sure to hit the like button for me
and leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway and also you know if you got
any suggestions for videos you'd like to
see let me know you know I love hearing
your feedback
you know today's video
um on trading around value areas
actually came from one of my uh private
training sessions uh yesterday Wednesday
um
I just didn't have time to cover it
there but you know it was a very valid
uh topic that you know I think a lot of
Traders would be interested in knowing
more about so that's why I'm making this
video for you guys today so
when you're looking at Value okay
and in the order flow when I talk about
value areas I'm talking about
um you know sort of in the profile sense
you know the market profile volume
profile
um you know determining the value area
as seventy percent of where the volume
trades over a certain period of time
what I do is I break it down but onto a
bar basis I mean honestly you know
people they come into the markets and
they don't realize right they they read
a book or something or watch a video and
think that's the way you have to trade
right value is something that that is
developed over time and it's up to you
to determine your time I just so happen
to use it on a bar by bar basis I could
use uh you know a shorter time I could
use a longer time it really comes down
to you I know some guys that will look
at a profile for the entire week and see
the value for that week I mean they're a
different type of Trader than I am I am
a short-term Trader a day trader I'm in
and out uh during the day many times if
and I'm not looking to hold a position
for a long period of time I'm just
looking to
um you know I'm like a little bird right
flying around you know picking up the
you know I'm not trying to pick up the
whole piece of bread all at once I'm
just trying to pick up you know just
enough to uh take back to the nest come
back get some more go back get some more
Etc so you know the same concept would
apply I'm going to talk about you know a
minute based chart a range base chart
and but it doesn't matter if you're you
know using a one minute chart
um or 30 second chart or a 15 minute
chart or a 30 minute chart or a four
hour chart a daily chart a weekly chart
value is is value in the sense of
where majority of the volume is trading
okay so we'll start here this is a uh an
eight range chart you know
a lot of times I do videos I I show it
on a you know on a minute based chart
people say hey can you show me on a
range base chart okay so I'm going to
show you both um because you know we all
trade different chart types
and
the same Concepts apply whether you're
looking at an eight range chart uh a
1987 tick chart or you know whatever
okay value is where 70 of the volume
occurs now again you can break it down
to what you determine right if you want
to look at you know we're 70 of the
volume appears in a five minute period
you can if you want to look at you know
where the value areas over an eight
minute period you can there's nobody
says that no you can't do it that way
okay I know some people out there you
know they make this is how you have to
trade and if you don't trade this you
know you're doing it wrong remember
right that's what makes the market
everyone has a difference of opinion
everyone has a different way of
approaching the market so this is a
eight range e-mini chart
and it's just a simple footprint chart
right no you know you just got your
uh point of control you got your
imbalances and you see the volume on the
bid the volume on the offer so
if you're using the order flows Trader
software we make it very easy for you
okay so you can see up here in this
indicator settings right value area
percent it default is set to 70. and
then you're going to scroll down into
the settings in here and you're going to
find the value area okay you're just
going to enable it now you can have it
fixed like this
or until tested now we have two types so
we have value area we have engulfing
value area
um
I'll get into the engulfing value area a
little bit later but first we'll start
with just sort of your fixed value areas
okay then click apply click OK and give
it a second for the chart to come up
here
all right so now all right I see in
addition to the point of control in the
bars
I see another box inside of the bar in a
sense that is the value area that's
where 70 of the value occurs now the
order flow is Trader software
if it's a green up candle it's going to
color the value area green if it is a
red down candle it will color the value
area red you can actually adjust that
and if it's uh just so happens to be a
doji bar that opens and closes at the
same price level it will color the value
area gray now if you wanted to adjust
these colors
you could simply just go into the
settings
go in here right and you can change
value areas right you can see black for
doji's green for bullish and red for
bearish okay and it's black you know the
color of the candle on the outside of
the box I'm fine with it black
and so there you go there you have your
value Aries now it's from these value
areas that you can start to get assessed
now remember these are this is an eight
range bar
chart so
each bar is going to have a value area
just says each bar would have a point of
control
and you know how do you want to use it
well okay ideally you know you're
looking for these areas right usually
value is going to overlap in a way okay
and you know you can see these areas
where These Bars were like in here right
value is mostly overlapping where it
gets gets interesting right if you're
looking at a bar by bar basis is you're
looking at these gaps between the value
area low and the value area high in red
candles or in green candles from the
value area high to the value area low of
the next candle okay and you know I like
to see these areas I call these
abandoned value areas
and again you have a choice of how you
want to color if you just want to see
the value areas like this okay that's
one way I like to draw it out what we
call until tested okay so I'm going to
go back into the settings
and I'll make that quick change there so
you can see the value areas just in each
bar what I'm going to do is I'm going to
draw it out until tested okay
and what you're going to see now is when
a market is moving away from value
immediately right immediately meaning
the next bar so for example here right
I've got this swing low
got this valuator down here towards the
bottom of the bar then the next bar it
gaps up in this value right it doesn't
even test it gets within you know a tick
two ticks of that value area here
it hasn't tested it really it just came
down got within two ticks then rallied
up same thing in the next bar
you have this value area that's
hasn't been tested you got one two three
four five and then the opposite starts
happening as you start coming down now
how I look at these
is I pay special attention to these if
we're at a swing high or a swing low
because really what I'm trying to focus
on is where is this shift in value okay
if I'm at a swing low
and I have a value area that's not
tested in the next bar right like here
right we're coming down we're sort of
testing each value area as we're going
down in the next bar
okay now there's a bearish one obviously
but we're on a downtrend really what I'm
looking for is an area where the market
can potentially change and start to
rally and it comes right here
after this bar closes now you don't know
until this bar here at 8 57 and 39
seconds closes that it's not going to
trade in there because you know if the
bar is still trading it could very well
trade back in there but I know that once
this bar closes that's my signal
they'll look to take the trade you know
from 35 and a half
and it trades all the way up into the
40s and then I get up here to a swing
High
and it starts to reverse right it's not
trading back into the next Mars value to
me that is a sign of a market that has
some momentum that is moving now this is
a
eight range chart if I was looking at
you know a called a you know a one
minute chart
I'll just make that change really quick
here
and then take a look right
same thing I'll just sort of go back
here in time you know to wherever uh you
know where's Cash open Cash open right
here okay you know wait for some sort of
sign I hear it looked like okay we came
down here a little swing low maybe it
can start to Rally then it came back in
and tested once it starts testing
okay then I know that okay we're not
running yet
let me just make this change here this
is ninja Traders frustrating sometimes
it
sometimes it just goes in automatically
resets this bar with the 100 which is
like the max and I can't expand it
then here we go right we come into a
swing low I've got a value area
next bar it's abandoned all right it
doesn't test it
and you get a nice move from you know
the 38 all the way up into the 42s this
one again you know if I was looking to
get long I would have been stopped out
here okay fine I'm gonna look for the
next one because I'm looking for this
move to start Market start moving
okay it started moving here but then it
comes back in with a bearish value area
at a swing high it's abandoned it's my
sign to get short
okay
and you can see how often times these
value areas act as support or resistance
right like right here it comes right
back to that area right here's the value
area from before it came comes right
back trades a lot of volume in here
fourteen hundred a thousand
okay here right it's a nice swing low
doesn't trade back in starts going up
you should be getting long in this bar
then you get another signal you know
another one here coming in
where's my target it's this value area
from earlier up here around the 40 area
so if I'm long
you know from 33 I know that you know
you get up to 40 that's my potential
Target if we get up to 40 you know we
might stall out a bit and that what do
we do that's what we do we get up to 40
and we sort of stall there right then we
start picking up some more steam in here
we got another value area that's
untested here
um you know let me just start making
these smaller new highs so again it
doesn't matter what Market you're
looking at what chart type this is a one
minute chart if
you know I don't you know I don't
necessarily look at five minute charts
but I'd be looking for the same thing if
I was going on a five minute chart right
right here right swing low
value area Market rallies up
on the way down after you hit that high
value area that's untested here you get
short where does it stop it stops right
down here where you have your value area
from earlier that's what I'm talking
about when I say these value areas act
as support for resistance right
resistance it trades right up in two
ticks into this value area
and comes off again
right here it came three ticks into this
value area
you know cash what was this cash this is
the bar the cash close we can see you
know anytime you have these value areas
that don't get tested at least in the
next bar it could be a sign of a move
that's about to happen
um this is you know e-minis I don't know
let's take a look at bonds
on a five minute chart okay now again on
bonds
I like four range but again I'm also
curious to see how it looks on you know
different chart types okay obviously you
know we had some numbers today
but we get up you know this one and
people say well yeah it went up then it
came right back down okay well this is
in the middle of an area right I I was
explaining before I'd like to see them
on swing highs or swing lows or ideally
swing highs or swing lows or after a
swing High you know on the next bar it
came in here
for a nice you know short and you can
see it's acting as resistance right I
don't think we even got anywhere near
there the rest of the day
um
you know I like actually I like range
based charts on on bonds you can see
here right swing high right here
value area
not tested game what came within a tick
of it and then we had this nice sell-off
right where's my targets I got a Target
here I've got a Target here
okay now I've got a bullish one coming
in right here okay where does it stop it
stops here where the value area is
coming in
right and it starts working its way back
down gets through these okay then it
starts reversing at your low of the day
you got a bar with the value area where
it's not tested in the next bar then the
second bar test it gets inside
but then it rallies up okay
here you got a doji one that's why it's
gray color
um
no I mean it all markets I don't know
take a look at gold like Golds
Goldfinger
um
what is this the range based charts you
know I mean probably using if I'm
looking at Gold you know I think eight
range is fine or even a a one minute
chart is fine you can see on a market
that's running value area that's not
tested in the next BAR value where
you're not tested an X BAR value where
you're not tested value area not tested
value area not tested value area that's
how you know the Market's got a head of
steam right when you start seeing one
two three four five and go I mean you
don't need to wait to the oh I got ten
no you want to get in as soon as
possible once I start seeing them sort
of
Bunch up like this one two you know even
three to me that that's a sign of a
strong move just like here you got one
okay anything a little sideways and
another one coming in
okay there's one here's another one
right you get a nice move up
here you got one two trades back out up
in there and you know I there are some
Traders out there that you know once I
introduced this they loved it
immediately they they told me this Jesus
I wish I had this
long ago because what they do is they
just wait for the pullback in there
and then the rejection right like this
right it's coming off pulls back in then
starts coming out especially if it
leaves a value area like this that's not
tested
they just Pile in on that move right
um
you know here got one comes in okay it
starts moving up pulls back again to
that level you know this area here pulls
back in here pulls back again into this
one as well as this one
so there's many different ways you can
trade it
all right I mean you could trade it on a
pullback you could trade it as a you
know go with that trade immediately
um you could use it you could use these
as targets right if you're long
you know and you're starting running
into a bunch of overhead
you know value areas from earlier
the market might start to stumble at
some of these areas just as it did here
right with this one I mean it got
through these two little ones
that is stumbled up again here all right
you got some overhead one got through
this little one here then it starts
stumbling around this area where you
have these value areas from earlier
okay so you know that that's my little
video on trading the order flow value
areas on a bar by bar basis and again it
doesn't matter whether you're using a
one minute chart whether you're using a
range based chart if you're using a tick
bass chart or a volume based chart
you trade it the same right this is uh
what do I what I pull up here 200 tick
chart okay same things all right value
area it's not tested valuatory that's
not tested value area that's not tested
I mean this one in my opinion is the Spy
the strongest one because it's coming in
at the swing low
you know come up here make a swing High
pull off make another run back up
towards That Swing High evaluate that's
not tested
but there's a lot of different ways to
trade them right you gotta start
thinking how you can adapt this tool of
order flow into your own Trading
so I'll end this video
on value areas I hope you found it
useful and again you know if you find
these videos useful and helpful for your
understanding of order flow let me know
by leaving a nice comment below and you
know be sure to put something in in the
comments section you know to what you'd
like me to discuss next by
um you know but just simply leaving a
simple comment below so if you enjoying
this video be sure to hit the like
button and subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss any more videos thanks
everyone bye-bye